do you believe that or you don't believe
that I believe it um but there's a lot
of stuff that yeah because well you know
you know what differentiate Islam not
because I'm a Muslim what differentiate
Islam from any religion Islam goes in
line with our Universal knowledge what
is our Universal knowledge is our sound
reasoning like naturally intellectually
there's no way a man that was created to
be God doesn't make any sense cuz by
definition is God and created correct
God has no beginning or end yeah if you
say God has no beginning or end but at
the same time Jesus Is God and he was
created that doesn't make any sense that
is a paradox literally you don't have to
be a Muslim or a Christian or a fire
worshipper to utilize your sound
reasoning to understand that doesn't
make any sense likewise Trinity when you
come Trinity they say the father is God
Jesus is God the holy spirit is God and
they are not true God they are one God
but even that that doesn't make any says
bro even even even read the Bible when
when when Jesus said he said oh here all
children of Israel the Israelite our God
is one God not not the Holy Spirit also
when Jesus said the only one that knows
the hour the day of judgment is the
father not the holy spirit so if the
Holy Spirit doesn't know the hour if
jesuses know the hour how how can they
be God you understand bro doesn't make
any sense I'm not reading into I have to
read yeah yeah check out I me I mean my
wife she's a re by the way my wife she
was a Christian and she left it you know
she became Muslim when she I mean yeah
she became Muslim when she was 17 and
that's what one of the thing that
literally made her think twice about
Christianity is that if Jesus Is God how
he was praying to God I don't get that
like that's a from M girl so basically
there this Christian guy so he was
trying to say like explain about the
Holy Trinity thing I was like but how is
Jesus good I don't understand cuz as
Jesus isn't like how are you guys
praying to Jesus he's not like the
almighty like Allah is the almighty like
there obviously someone he created Jesus
do you get what I mean no but they they
say there's a trinity in it they they
because no even the Christian don't
understand it it's not because not
because you know why because he goes
back to paganism it goes back to the
Romans you know let me tell you
something the Bible no it's
not in a way you can try to extrapolate
it but it's not clear it's not it's not
clear it's not clear like like when when
you look to for example Jesus died for
your sins that is not in the Bible when
the young boy came to Jesus he said oh
good Master what should I do to go to
heaven so imagine Jesus standing now and
you come to ask him how can I enter to
Heaven Paradise Jesus said to him keep
the Commandments of God which is the
Torah yeah the young boy they said to
Jesus I have been doing it since I was
young Jesus said to him but you are lack
in one thing he said what is it he said
give your wealth away and follow me so
so here because we believe as a Muslims
the best advisers are the prophets and
The Messengers and including Jesus Jesus
without any doubt he will tell that
young boy what is the best way to enter
Paradise he never told him believe I'm
going to die for your sins and you'll be
saved that is Paul teaching that's why a
lot of Christians of our time they don't
follow Jesus literally they follow Paul
and who is Paul Paul who his name was
Saul he used to go around kill
Christians then he said one day on the
way to Damascus God appeared to him
he said so so why you killing my
servants but again he he was known to be
a liar criminal a murderer you how you
going to trust him there was no
Witnesses
Paul yeah Paul he we believe as a Muslim
Paul he changed the teaching of Jesus
Propet no no Paul is not Prophet no no
no Paul is just what we believe that
even if you can when you study history
even from the uh the Christian sources
when Paul noticed the true followers of
Jesus they were strong in their beliefs
and they would die for their belief
leaves he knew that he would not they
they're going to submit to him so what
he did he changed a game he pretended to
be follow of Jesus and what he did he
changed the teaching of Jesus from
within that's why some who half Jesus
Jesus half brother and um where's the
other one PR both of them they disagree
with Paul cuz Paul was going around he
said it's not about the law anymore it's
about believing Jesus died for your sins
so when he came to Jerusalem they told
him is that true he said no if it's not
true then sacrifice a sheep cuz that's
what the Israelites us to do and guess
what when you go to Paul laters it's
true he said that so he was lying though
so how I'm going to follow Paul and
leave Jesus teaching when it was clear
there's only one God I believe Jesus was
a messiah without any doubt I believe
Jesus was able to by Allah's permission
to bring dead people back to alive but
not God or a son of God let me tell
about the 25th of December do you know
who was born on 25th of
December MRA MRA is a son god of the
Greeks so hold a minute 25th December
mythra is a day that when the sun god of
the Greeks was born but we have
Christmas day 2th December Jesus was
born but when you go to the Bible Jesus
Jesus was not born in decm you
understand Palestine because he says
that the Sheep were going out late night
and in Palestine that mean around the
summertime you understand so you can see
the Romans when they want to accepted
when they want to accept ity they had to
mix paganism with some of the teaching
of Jesus that goes in line with their
agenda you understand that's why the
Romans mixed up the Jewish teaching
that's why I believe Prophet Muhammad
wasam he came after one of the the
wisdom of God sending Prophet Muhammad
to correct some of the lies that has
been attribute to Jesus even like when
you when you look to Prophet Muhammad's
biography yeah it's so powerful he shows
this man is a trustworthy honest you
know during his lifetime eclipse
happened you know Eclipse yeah occurred
so when his companion saw that it was
the same day when his son passed away
ibraim his son yeah they tried to
connect the dots so eclipse happened his
son died therefore because of his son
cuz they were not familiar they didn't
know why this Eclipse Prophet Muhammad
if was a liar cuz remember a liar will
try to utilize any opportunity to back
up his claim correct but what he did he
said no what has occurred has nothing to
do with no one's life no one's death
that's from God then he gave a talk
about being grateful to God worship God
prepare yourself for the day of judgment
he didn't even speak about his son and
so compare this story with crossover
Columbus Christopher Columbus when he
went to America and the the Native
Americans they saw eclipse and they
didn't know why there's Eclipse he told
them God is not happy with you so give
us your land so look how Prophet
Muhammad utilized the same event but he
never manipulat his followers he told
him what happens from
God but Christopher Columbus who was a
Christian catholic christian who went to
spread Christianity in America he
utilized the ignorance of people to
manipulate them so that shows you what
prophet Muhammad is a truthful man
honest man I can give you another one
which prophet Muhammad his friend yeah
he was married to a woman that woman she
start hating him so much she start
hating his friend so he divorced her
then he was following her the street
Prophet Muhammad said to his companions
are you not amazed how much she hated
him or she hates him and how much he
loves her so Prophet Muhammad
went to him went to her he said to her
why don't you go back to him she said oh
messenger of Allah because she believes
he was a messenger of Allah yeah she
said oh messenger of Allah is it what
you saying to me is it a commandment
from Allah or you try to
mediate imagine he was a liar cuz
remember he if someone claim to be a
prophet of God there's no one liar like
him he's the biggest liar what he could
have done if he was a liar he could have
manipulated her by say to her yeah you
know what God told me so go back to him
and love him yeah he said no God never
told me this has to do with God's
teaching I'm just I'm I'm just trying to
mediate bro you can see this man's a
characteristic of a truthful and honest
the other one look Prophet Muhammad
prophecies yeah he said will come a time
you know interest yeah interest usually
yeah yeah yeah you become widespread
even if you are not involved directly
will affect you Prophet Muhammad existed
1,400 years ago there was not any
indication to indicate that would occur
that will come a time when interest and
usually become widespread Now by default
if you open a bank account you are
involved in
interest bro how interest is Haram no I
will tell you what interest is Haram
interest is Haram because why you are
manipulating people poverty to enslave
them yeah so for example imagine you
come to me say
Shi and it's £60 I say I will give you
£60 but give it to me by next week but I
know you you're not going to give it to
me by next week so so you come back say
I can't give give it to you I said okay
no problem give it to me
£80 back then I know by two weeks you're
not going to do that so imagine I'm
doing that on a big scale what I'm doing
I'm making a poor poorer and a rich
richer you see that's why Islam comes in
and I'll mention what what Islam is so
powerful yeah Islam come to preserve
five things watch this yeah Islam came
to preserve five things first one Islam
come to preserve religion that's why
Islam paganism politicism is forbidden
because when you have no God when you
have no guideline from the Creator we
start following our desires and this
what's happening right now in our
society that a man wakes up if it's a
woman a woman wakes up she she's a man a
man wakes up if think I'm an animal have
you heard the guy you know there was a
guy here
literally yeah hey bro bro there's a guy
here he believes he's a dog but he's
been trapped within human body they
brought him on ITV show good morning
yeah he says yeah he literally he wear
the suit you know dog suit and there's
another woman she got married to
herself yeah yeah but guess what bro two
months later they put what woman cheesed
on
herself what happened she got married to
another person that's my point you see
when you have no God in your life you
start following subjectivity your
desires that's why Allah said the Quran
if if a people follow their desires the
heavens and the Earth be corrupted the
story if the truth if the truth follow
people desires the heavens and the Earth
be corrupted that's why the truth is not
about your desires I like it so I have
to follow it no it's about the truth so
that's why Islam paganism polytheism is
forbidden secondly Islam came to
preserve intellect that's why alcohol
and drugs is
forbidden thirdly Islam came to preserve
wealth that's why interest and gambling
is forbidden fourthly Islam came to
preserve uh Soul that's why killing
people unjustly is forbidden there's a
capital punishment likewise Islam came
to preserve marriage you know that's why
fornication adultery is forbidden cuz
when there's fornication adultery when
you have children sometimes the man
doesn't care so you know there's no
connection there's no right whatsoever
yeah so when you see these five things
that Islam came to preserve let us look
at the opposit what does gambling have
to do with that gambling destroy
people yeah so I'm going to ask you now
alcohol is it good for people or
bad yes it's bad in some way it's bad
you know alcohol is like you stabbing
yourself it's like you cutting yourself
slowly that's what you're doing to
yourself that's what you do to your
kidney even a little now scientifically
proven Ali can you get that research
about s scientist about the alcohol even
consuming they say even cons now
scientist they say yeah even consuming a
little is
dangerous so my point here here is that
Islam comes to say don't drink not
because Allah hates you you see now
gambling gambling destroy families
destroy societies yeah uh interest
likewise interest make the rich richer
poor
poor study not amount of drink alcohol
is safe for brain health so likewise
like so the five destroy of societies
which is alcohol gambling adultery
fornication Islam comes to work against
it and all of this evils goes back to
the most evil thing when you turn away
from your God's teaching and you start
following you desires so the question
you ask yourself if this is the case if
Islam comes to preserve Our Lives
preserve our intellect preserve our
health and so on so why some people hate
Islam there's two type of people hate
Islam either they're ignorant or those
who are making money from the suffering
of the people imagine I'm from London I
have a Banks I have a gambling shops I
have all of these evil things yeah and
you come as a Muslim teaching people
about Islam of course I'm going to look
at you as an evil person even though
you're a good person you want good for
society
but remember you Tred to make me
bankrupt and I'm making money from the
stuff of the people but I don't care I'm
an evil man so what I'm going to do I'm
going to utilize my wealth to make you
look bad and this what's happening right
now those who are in charge or in power
they are utilizing their wealth to make
Islam look bad through the media even
though Islam is the best way of life
make sense yeah it makes sense yeah let
me ask you this question yeah imag you
what's your name by the way hug huh hug
my name sh Huga yeah imagine I said to
you bro ni bro imagine I said to you
look I'm a trillionaire
I have too much money yeah I've been
having nice discussion with you I give
You2 million as a gift as a gift I don't
want nothing from you as a gift as a
person of Honor what would you say to me
at
least you're going to thank me you're
going to you're going to of course if
you take it you're going to me all the
time2 million is a big money correct I
will give You2 million on a condition
give me your two
eyes you will not take it why because
your eyes is more valuable than 22
million so why we are not grateful and
remember who gave us I for
free see that's why when you look God's
God's blessings on us is so massive you
know imagine in a house and you are
surround with a fire you try your best
to save yourself yeah you try your best
but you couldn't save yourself I came
and I saved your life what would you say
to me thank you thank you would you
remember me all the time yeah good bro I
never gave you life
though why the one gave you life he gave
it to you for free bro why don't you
remember him why don't you thank him why
you not grateful to him because you are
too busy the second question I ask you
if you want to buy a gift for your
mother imagine you want to buy a gift
for your mother would you buy a gift
that your love or your mother
love Mom love likewise if you want to
worship the Creator and be grateful to
him who has given us we should do it the
way he loves not the way we love because
the way he loves is objective the way
way we love is subjective so when you
look to Islam that is you know sh when
someone become Muslim that is based upon
that I bear witness there's no one
worthy of worship except Allah I should
appreciate my Creator I should be
grateful to my Creator and Muhammad the
messenger of Allah that's what Islam
about of course there's other pillars
Like a Prayer yeah no doubt about that
fasting you know even fasting you know
many people say poor people but when you
fast you feel it you fting day serious
Monday
that's good you know so I'm say hey look
you see what I do she knows I'm online I
give da that's what I do I preach you
know what I say to people if Islam makes
sense to you and it goes in line with
universal knowledge that is a sign the
one who created you is the same one who
sent down that Revelation you understand
it's like you have a routa and you have
a phone and both goes in line with the
Wi-Fi you know what I'm saying so you
clearly okay the one I give all the time
is like imagine make a car I'm the first
person to make a car
yeah and I gave you guideline he gave
you guideline she give you guideline
none of them works except mine but all
of us we may we are making the claim
that we made the car if the only
guideline that works is mine so
therefore who made it it's me so we look
Islamic teaching it goes in line with
our Universal knowledge that we have
universally worldwide I'm talking about
every child every human being has it our
sound Ison in natural ination and our
perceptions you know we look to Islam is
a perfect way of life prayers we pray to
allaha when a prayer because Islam teach
you submission submit to your creator
intellectually uh spiritually and
physically we bound down we prostrate it
just makes you're a better person it
makes you're a better person without any
doubt like you have subconsciously like
Allah in the back of your head no about
that you do like oh like Allah like is
watching me yeah no no doubt yeah no
doubt about that no doubt about that
that's why you look you know you know
let me ask you see if you don't know
which countries are the happiest
countries in the world African countries
huh African countri no they they don't
say Africa Africa is well M Africa but
it's not it's not you know which country
they say Japan and Sweden but watch this
yeah watch watch they say Japan and
Sweden but guess the highest rate of
suicide is in Japan and
Sweden so how happy they are the nonb
the most nonbelievers yeah atheist love
of atheism there yeah but how they happy
you know how what they mean they're
happy mean the happiest mean they get
good money good work good money good
wage they have good houses but that's
not true happiness that's why Allah said
the
Quran is it not is it not with the
remembrance of Allah the heart will find
peace and Tranquility when you are
connected with your creator the true
creator the one who deserves to worship
alone and you follow his teaching that
is the meaning of true happens you know
because one day we're going to die bro
you know I always mention this how many
people left the house they never come
back how many people would sleep they
never wake up that's why you know we
should think that you know that's why
Prophet Muhammad wasallam said go to the
graveyard the graveyard tells you the
reality of this life the life that we
are boycotting each other for the life
that we are fighting for the life that
one day we're going to go to the Grave
that are Graves those who are inside the
graves they were like you and I and her
stand there talking joking now they are
in inside the graves nothing will
benefit them before the Creator except
their believes and the
actions understand and let me give you
another ex sorry for taking your time as
well you know sorry I'm going to give
you another example yeah show you look
when you have no God you will contradict
yourself fundamentally
yeah rape is illegal in this country
yeah selling drugs is illegal okay uh
gang's life stabbing people is illegal
correct
but at the same time we are teaching
that to our children to the youth but at
the same time we are allowing the
singers pay them ridiculous money to
glorify and glamorize all these device
all these evil devices so on one hand
you teaching the children don't steal
Don't drink don't disrespect women don't
stop people so and so such and such but
yet you bringing a singest to him and
you give them big money why people are
dying out of hanger and so on and you
tell them don't do that but yet you
allow this person to glamorize and
glorify Islam comes in
now is we have a principle whatever
leads to evil it's
evil Islam doesn't say to a child yeah
take a knife but take care of it it's a
child they understand so Islam comes in
now you know these people should not no
one should give them platform because
they glamorize div evil devices you
understand so you know these people they
should be t you know but again when you
have no God that is the outcome of that
and Allah mentioned that in the
Quran whoever turns away from my
remembrance from the remembrance of
Allah then he will have a miserable life
you know the Western world is like
someone the Western world is like
someone
uh has a broken leg I mean broken arm
broken leg it's cut everywhere you know
has his eyes sharp he most M Shar so
what he does he put a nice suit he put a
nice glasses a nice mask that's the wor
in
world back home like from Africa I'm
from Africa too back home when you watch
video movies about the Western World
Hollywood you think when you come here
they have a keys for you they have a
nice car for you nice house for you but
when you come here you know you
understand so that's how the W most dece
so what would you recommend for like
someone who's like just learning about
Islam and like you know step by step
Foundation example I give always is like
imagine you eating a whole cake imagine
you have a big cake front of you yes and
you eat all of it at once what will
happen get sick get sick yeah you vomit
you understand in order to feel the
sweetness of the cake what you do you
take it bit by bit Islam step by step
that's why what I was doing brother I
was explaining to you the foundation of
Islam cuz if the foundation is clear and
it makes sense and is IR rational and
logical and believe you know what it
makes sense it's true then to to become
I'm not school about I'm not school of
Islam I'm still learning likewise I'm
not perfect I have my own struggles you
understand all of us have our own
struggles you understand but yet if
something is clear accept you know uh
it's like the example I give it's like
going to the GP you know sometimes your
GP will tell you to take something
medication and you you know what I don't
understand why he's telling me that but
you do trust him because you are working
with the the Foundation that he's an
expert even though you don't know his
shoe size even though you don't know how
many children he has but you know to
trust him you are working with a
foundation he's an expert he knows what
he's talking about so when it com to
Islam if the foundation is clear then to
learn more in depth there's no harm with
that but if the foundation is clear you
become Muslim alhamdulillah except you
have any question you have any question
no no I'm just clear makes sense
alhamdulillah if you want to become
Muslim now I'll be happy but but if you
want to read make my day that would make
my day but if you want it's up to you
you know what I'm saying that if you
want to read more there's no har with
that but something you have to remember
is death brother like I said you know is
it clear does it make sense yeah it
makes sense you believe it's
true I can't say I believe it I haven't
read it but if he makes sense and it's
clear and it's rational and he goes in
line with that's that's the words that
you said but I want to read into it you
read more yeah read no problem inah uh
check where I'm not from here I'm from
Bush where you from uh up from
Southfield South London where if you
don't mind Southfield Southfield South
okay you're not far from me I'm from
Bush oh yeah yeah South because I still
live in South where about I still live
in l oh L yeah yeah l i was everywhere
bro I live in Lu new Cross Gates newor
Cross Beam statford everywhere bro
alhamdulillah h no no no we I'm I'm
every Friday outside sh station
that's where I'm from oh
[Music]
okay is it on Friday I don't know cuz
there's people come on Saturday it's not
us but us every Friday there it's
probably
Saturday
yeah yeah because every Friday we are
there alhamdulillah because of Ramadan
so we don't stay there we don't stay
longer but outside Ramadan we are there
from 1:00 all the way to 8:00 p.m. yeah
you're welcome brother my brother it was
nice looking to you man thank you very
much take care of yourself brother yeah
you too man